you guys say reinvent myself it's just
that I want to be up more than anybody
in the planet want me to be down and
that's just what it's all about wanting
to get the best out of yourself not
competing with anyone else but you and
that's how we improve as a person
improving
ourselves to an emotional level where
sometimes you can feel uh superior but
it's Superior in a good way cuz we we
sharing a lot of love and everybody's
going to be superior in that same level
cuz that's what it's all about everybody
being equal some people have more
flamboyant jobs more money but the
psychology of just Brotherly Love
sisterly love and we just have to get
along that's just what it is